in this video I'll demonstrate my
technique for recreating a shot from the
1923 title sequence using After Effects
and a little AI
[Music]
hi my name is Cameron and I'm the
creator of motion science before we get
started I wanted to invite you to join
my complimentary workshop at
motionscience.tv Workshop where I unveil
my personal techniques and hidden gems
that I use in my daily workflows this is
a free workshop and takes about 30
minutes don't miss out on this chance to
level up your skills and make sure to
visit
motionscience.tv Workshop after watching
this video you won't regret it in this
video I'll be using the AI tool
mid-journey Photoshop and after effects
to create a vintage Cowboy themed title
sequence shot to start off we'll be
using the powerful AI tool mid-journey
to generate our Cowboy portrait simply
type in your prompt such as imagine a
cowboy portrait and let mid-journey do
the rest in just a few seconds you will
have a beautiful image mid-journey is an
incredible tool that can save you a lot
of time and effort so make sure to take
advantage of it after generating the
cowboy portrait using mid-journey the
next step is to extract a depth map in
Photoshop to do this open the cowboy
portrait in Photoshop 2023 or newer and
use the neural filter depth blur to
extract a depth map a depth map is a
grayscale image that represents the
distance of each pixel in the image from
the camera once the depth map is
generated we need to invert it so that
the brightest white represents the parts
of the image that are closest to the
camera while the darker areas represent
the parts that are further away to
invert the depth map in Photoshop go to
image in the top menu and select
adjustments and then invert now it's
time to import Photoshop file into after
effects to do this import the Photoshop
file as a composition so that after
effects Imports both the image and the
depth map layers next select the cowboy
portrait layer and add a displacement
map effect to it in the effects control
panel choose the depth map layer as the
displacement map Source the displacement
map will now distort the cowboy portrait
based on the grayscale values of the
depth map to fine tune the effect and
remove some of the Distortion weirdness
you need to add blur to the depth map
this will help to blend the white and
gray values and make the effect look
more natural to add blur to the death
map select the depth map layer and add a
fast box blur effect to it it's
important here that you change Source in
the displacement map effect to effects
and masks so that the displacement
effect recognizes the blur that is
applied to the depth map to animate the
displacement effect add keyframes to the
displacement properties at the beginning
and end of the timeline this will create
an animation that gradually distorts the
cowboy layer over time you can adjust
the timing and intensity of the effect
by adjusting the keyframes in the
timeline by using the displacement map
effect on the cowboy portrait layer we
were able to create a dynamic and
interesting movement effect that gives
the impression of depth and dimension
after creating the displacement effect
on the cowboy layer it's time to
position the portrait in the final
composition start by creating a new
composition drag the cowboy portrait
layer into the timeline of the new
composition then position the portrait
according to the rule of thirds by
following the rule of thirds when
positioning the cowboy in the
composition we can create a more
visually interesting and compelling shot
that draw pause the viewer's attention
to the most important elements in the
frame to add a textured background to
the composition we can search for a
suitable rough paper texture online once
we have a suitable texture we can import
it into After Effects drag the texture
file into the composition and place it
below the cowboy layer by adding a rough
paper texture to the background of the
composition we can create a more
interesting and Visually engaging shot
that adds depth and texture to the final
image to create a vintage look for the
composition we can add an adjustment
layer in After Effects by selecting
layer new adjustment layer this will
create a new layer that affects all
layers below it in the timeline we can
then apply color correction effects such
as lumetri color and CC toner lumetri
color is a powerful color grading tool
that allows us to adjust the exposure
contrast color balance and other
parameters of the image one effective
technique for creating a vintage look is
to use the vignette and Faded film
parameters in lumetri color the vignette
effect darkens the edges of the image
while The Faded film effect adds a
softer look to the color dollars and
contrast by adjusting the settings of
these effects we can create a custom
vintage look that suits the style of the
shot this process can involve a lot of
trial and error but with some patience
and experimentation we can create a
custom vintage look that complements the
style of the shot and enhances its
overall impact we can further enhance
the overall aesthetic of the composition
by adding grain and a curves effect to
do this we can apply the add grain
effect to an adjustment layer we can
adjust the settings of the grain effect
to our preference depending on how much
grain we want to add to the image next
we can add a curves effect to an
adjustment layer we can use the curves
effect to tweak the highlights mid-tones
and Shadows of the image to fine tune
the overall look after applying the
Grain and curves effect we should have a
vintage looking composition with a
consistent and cohesive visual style to
create a sense of depth and realism we
will make the cowboy and background
layers 3D we'll start by selecting the
cowboy layer and clicking on the 3D
layer icon next we'll add a 3D camera to
the composition by selecting layer new
camera with the cam camera layer
selected we can animate it to slowly
push into the scene creating a sense of
movement and depth to do this we'll add
keyframes to the position property of
the camera layer starting with the
camera positioned far away from the
scene and ending with the camera
positioning closer to the Cowboy
additionally we'll reverse the keyframes
of the cowboy displacement effect so
that the movement of the cowboy
complements the camera movement this
will create a more natural and organic
effect that looks as if the cowboy
portrait is reacting to the camera
movement by combining the 3D layers the
3D camera and the reverse keyframes we
can create a realistic and dynamic shot
that adds depth and movement to the
composition to make this shot a true
title sequence we can add a line of type
to the composition we can create a new
text layer in After Effects and position
it in the scene using again the rule of
thirds to add more visual interest to
the scene We'll add another texture to
the foreground of the composition we'll
make this layer 3D and position it
slightly further forward in Z space than
the cowboy layer this will create a
little Parallax effect as the camera
pushes in making the shot more Dynamic
to make sure the texture doesn't
overpower the rest of the composition
we'll play around with the position and
size until we find the right balance we
can also add a levels effect to reduce
the overall amount of texture in the
shot to complete the shot We'll add a
blurry vignette to the composition to
soften the edges this is done using an
adjustment layer with a mask and a fast
blur effect invert the mask and increase
the feather amount until the edges are
sufficiently softened this effect will
create a soft blurry border around the
edges of the composition drawing the
viewer's attention to the center of the
shot with the vignette effect in place
the shot is complete and ready for use
in the title sequence and there you have
it that's how you can recreate a shot
from the 1923 title sequence using the
AI tool mid Journey Photoshop and after
effects I hope this was both educational
and entertaining for you and if you
enjoyed the video please hit that like
button and consider subscribing to my
YouTube channel for more content like
this your support means the world to me
and helps me to continue creating
content I would love to hear your
thoughts on the video so please leave a
comment or question below thank you for
watching and I look forward to
connecting with you in my next video
[Music]